hey sebastian so um how does it feel
when people
say to you and anthony like i'm speaking
with the new leading men
of the marvel series no one's
said that to us ever oh then i'm the
first okay women let me get this right
then
let me get this right how does it feel
to have
marvel leading men status
i mean look at his shirt it looks great
is this a leading man shirt
oh is yellow is the color of happiness
there you go see there you go we're
doing a marvel calendar
are you mr march are you like
you know cuddle buddy wait you're the
falcon he's the winter soldier what are
you doing
that's what i'm saying i bring him
winter that's what i'm saying that's
what i'm saying
i have a plan really
[Music]
what is it
anthony is it true though that you were
a little afraid of being the face
of a marvel franchise like in case it
didn't work
no i was afraid of taking marvel being
the face of the first
marvel television show gotcha um
because i feel like the last thing you
want
is to be the lead of the first marvel
project that sucks
whoever that is your career is over
you're done well it ain't y'all
because first 10 minutes i was like
commercials for the rest of your career
like
i didn't want to be that guy so i don't
want to have to sell potty meat
in france because i destroyed marvel
i didn't want to do that so i was i was
very scared because i didn't think it
would translate the scope of the work
that we were able to do
on film i didn't think of a translated
challenge hey sebastian
you told um men's health magazine that
this is the best your body has ever
looked so you're getting in shape for
this calendar
apparently look at he's like you're
talking about a year ago right
yeah because that's not any any time
recently
um yeah there was a moment there was a
moment before we started shooting where
it was like around
august september of 2019 where i was
like yeah i i don't think i'll ever
get back to this it was like a little
moment in time where
where i felt okay about it and that's
when that shoot happened that's when he
took the picture
and posted it on ig half nuke right yes
that's what i did that's right i
remember that yeah yeah
you took the uh the eggplant picture
that's what we call it
oh eggplant pictures can't wait for
yours anthony
anytime you're ready to throw up throw
it on there
first flight tell me this though i mean
when you're that happy with your body
like what's that one
like muscle that you're like oh shoot i
didn't know i had that for me like when
i feel really good it's that little side
butt muscle that you're like whoa
that thing is actually it really exists
what's that one muscle that you like hot
damn i've really done it
uh oh answer this correctly and wisely
sebastian
until it's 20 21 sebastian
um you know i think it's so funny you
know like this whole thing of like when
you're so happy with your body it's like
you have body dysmorphia first of all
right like you it's entirely like it's
not
and and and prior to that picture it's
like you get this one window where
you're
where you're controlling your water
intake you're doing all these things and
then like you get this one winter for
two hours where you're like
looks like that and then the rest is
just not how it how it is all the time
you know hey anthony so we're coming off
the heels of
juan division which was a huge success
and really great and what they did i
felt like they really explored
grief in so many ways so what would you
say falcon winter soldier is an
exploration of
redemption um i think when you look at
these two characters and
you know you get their backstory and
what's going on with them it's really
them in a position
trying to redeem themselves for a
failures of time before times before
uh which is i think really important in
the uh
mcu you know everyone has something that
they want to make up for everyone has
something that they're trying to get
back to
so uh redemption in this um
series is very important to these
characters i thought it was interesting
too that that you guys took the time to
really kind of
have a conversation about what um you
represent as a black man in this world
and then in the bigger world where you
said you didn't feel like
you know carrying the shield because uh
how could you really be a black man
representing america in a country that
didn't necessarily represent him
i i love that so much i love that you
know
theme that's going to run through this
as well yeah definitely i mean i think
if you look at
just the overall scope
of the history of being a not even just
a black man a black person
in america the idea of you know
being captain america holds a certain
uh weight as the kids say nowadays
it just don't hit right right right
so what you're saying you know it's um
it's it's
uh it's hard to be able to accept that
and appreciate that
knowing the history and the lineage that
we all come from
um i know i'm gonna have to go but um
sebastian
you know with this this is being
released on your 10-year anniversary
of bringing uh bucky to the mcu
so do you even wrap your head around it
that you've been playing this character
for 10 years now
oh right 2011. uh yeah it's very strange
for sure
it's it's bizarre you know to think
about it because it's
been such a big part of this you know my
life in this decade for sure
so it's it's a blessing um you know
they're still willing to to call me i
guess
10 years of checks boy cut the check all
day
sebastian stan winning bang bang
bang bang my new agent uh
obviously here as well tonight